[Musik]
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
episode minecraft mit luca staffel 2 ich
werde mal direkt rüber laufen zu meiner
hütte wo ja noch einige items von mir
ich werde erstmal kurz schlafen gehen
und dann werde ich mal fix drüberlaufen
hier vorne zu meiner hütte wo ich ja
hier oben lapislazuli drin habe die
nehme ich jetzt nämlich mal genau ganz
schnell mit zusammen mit einem eisen
schwert weil ich das gleich verzaubern
werde und dass hier werde ich auch noch
mitnehmen das ist nämlich ein buch mit
schärfe 3 drauf das kann ich nämlich
gleich noch bei dem amboss
sind sie irgendwo noch mehr monster
war klar dass eine baby kommt von leute
tracks hier um mein gott ich muss ich
machte rating kz seite auf einmal kommt
von kripo aus der seite raus gelaufen
ich habe allerdings gar keinen er ablief
wo kommt der denn jetzt
noch einer oder
rezept
ich war gerade sagen ich hab gar keinen
mehr ab heute für diese ganzen monster
der zombies glaube ich hier vorne schon
verbrannt und beck keeper weiß ich nicht
wo der ist die sache ist allerdings dass
ich mir jetzt dann erstmal hier kurz ein
bisschen er dar außerdem werde das loch
da vorne stopfen werde und dann wird der
ein oder andere wahrscheinlich und
wissen doch was sollte hinauslaufen wird
denn ich werde zum ersten mal verzaubern
mir wurde zwar auch unten die kommentare
geschrieben und luca die tritscher
modifikation ist von einem krassen
vorteil denn dadurch kannst du peuple
fällen und wenn du dir dann irgend einem
tisch macht und wird dementsprechend von
beruf annimmt dann kannst du auch
stocker irgendwann gegen diamanten
tauschen oder irgendwie sowas diamant
rüstung oder adorno auf jeden fall muss
ich mich damit noch ein bisschen
auseinandersetzen denn ich kann ja mit
zwei endermann hier
und er ist weg
wir können mit der die shopper
modifikation einfach einen blog abbauen
dann geht der ganze baum den bach runter
ehrlich gesagt und das müssen demnächst
nochmal ein bisschen machen weil ich
wollte ich jetzt auch bald meine moi
einfach mal großflächig um
ich hab ich dir nicht angeguckt groß
vielleicht nicht um unser ganzes gebiet
hier drumrum bauen damit sie einfach
keine monster mehr reinkommt und so
weiter und so fort also danke auf jeden
fall für eure tipps die mauer werde ich
auf jeden fall bauen und das mit dem
verzaubern und der taktik mit dem
schöpfer werde ich auch machen die sache
ist allerdings dass ich jetzt mal mit
eisen schwert nehme lapislazuli rein
packe und wir können schärfe 3
tatsächlich darauf verzaubern das heißt
wir haben jetzt ein schärfe drei eisen
schwert was man schon mal sehr krass
weiterbringt ich hab
mir auch
schärfere auflagen schau mal was wir auf
einer achse drauf bekommen und zwar
effizienz zwei das bringt uns gar nichts
weil wir die tri top modifikation haben
und auf einer diamant spitzhacke hätten
wir haltbarkeit 2 und effizienz 1 ich
mache jetzt mal das hier drauf dann habe
ich nämlich haltbarkeit 2 drauf und die
hält noch mal ein bisschen länger und
ich hab immer noch 18 level das heißt
ich werde mir auf jeden fall erstmal
noch eine neue die 1
ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall mal meine
benutzte eine rüstung ausziehen und die
ich hier auf den rüstungs ständer
draufpacken benötige ich jetzt erst mal
nicht denn ich habe hier noch eine fast
komplett neue muss mir allerdings gleich
nochmal neue putz machen und ich werde
auch mal ganz kurz mir diese gold stufe
mit ihnen die benötige ich im netz
da werden wir heute auch noch hingehen
zunächst optisch allerdings erstmal
meine items die kurz rein ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich habe überhaupt kein plan bei
welchem satz ich schon aufgehört habe zu
heben um aller weise war es ja so dass
ich dann irgendwie sage ich sortiert
soll mal ganz kurz meine items rein weil
und dann sortiert 23 minuten rum um dann
zu sagen ich jetzt noch in die hölle
gehe allerdings gab
warum
welche die ganz egal ich habe allerdings
gerade auf jeden fall vergessen was ich
als letztes gesagt habe ist allerdings
egal denn ich habe mir jetzt hier eine
komplett neue eisen rüstung gemacht ich
glaube hier hatte ich auch noch zwei
sachen genau die sache jetzt jedoch dass
ich jetzt erstmal diese eisen rüstung
verzaubern werde das ist wirklich sehr
sehr sehr sehr wichtig wenn wir die
hölle gehen und dort von irgendwelchen
komischen knochen schlangen oder so
wieder angegriffen werden ich mache
jetzt mal das wichtigste das ist nämlich
der preisen harnisch der macht am
meisten haltbarkeit zwei hat er nur also
keinen schutz so wirklich drauf dann
nehme ich jetzt als nächstes mal die
hose da kriegen wir schon 2 das pack ich
auf jeden fall drauf auf die schuhe
haben wir wasserläufer und schutz 1 tage
nicht mehr schutz 1 bei dem helm haben
wir haltbarkeit 1 und schutzvereins und
bei dem eisen harnisch kommen ich habe
da jetzt einfach mal dass drauf was wir
hier ich habe keinen arbeitsplatz mehr
das war ein ganz klares zeichen dafür
gehen sollten ich mache mir jedoch ganz
kurz noch mal eine neue spitzhacke die
ich dann tatsächlich leider auch nochmal
unten kurz verzaubern muss und eine neue
schaufel weil die hier fast kaputt ist
das egal die kann nicht gut zusammen zu
einer machen dann muss ich die nicht
ohne die hier mit rumschleppen die sache
ist jedoch dass ich auf jeden fall meine
eisenspitzen ein bisschen verzaubern
möchte am besten mit effizienz zwei ich
habe immer noch kein nazi
ich bin so ein dummer idiot mit dem
kurzzeitgedächtnis nach vorne daher
können wir auch nicht weiter verzaubern
was uns allerdings jetzt zum richtigen
thema des heutigen videos führt denn
meine lieben freunde ich möchte heute
mit euch in die hölle gehen ich weiß
nicht ob wir vorne noch mein schild
drinnen liegt oder ob ich das mit noch
neben angenommen habe ich kann generell
war so ein paar sachen hier mitnehmen
wie eine menge erde oder so die ich halt
nebenan lagern möchte weil ich hier in
meiner hobbys oder eigentlich nur
wichtige sachen lagern möchte aber keine
richtig großen storage raum habe und ich
glaube mit der dauer des projekt werden
wir noch einige weitere items finden die
dort auf jeden fall den rahmen sprengen
werden deswegen möchte ich so was wie
erde zum beispiel er so hier drinnen
lagern die sache ist jedoch dass ich auf
jeden fall mich jetzt erst mal kurz
vorbereiten muss auf die hölle und ich
in dem zuge jetzt auch kurz meine reisen
achsen mit effizienz 3 beziehungsweise
stellvertreter zaubern werde ich weiß
dass effizienz keinen sinn macht mit der
tuba modifikationen allerdings habe ich
jetzt hier schärfe 3 drauf und hier
schärfe drei die macht 8 angriff schaden
also mein schwert und die axt macht elf
angriff schaden es ist dunkel draußen
ich kann aber nicht so eine strafe
allerdings
eigentlich auch ziemlich egal
weil ich so oder so ja in die hölle gehe
jedoch brauche ich noch ein paar blöcke
und da ich die allerdings in diesem
kleinen häuschen hier gelagert habe
würde ich sagen das bin doch vielleicht
mal ganz kurz uns ins bett bewegen so
dass wir uns nicht noch von einem
zweiten treffer in dieser folge in die
luft gesprengt werden ich habe ehrlich
gesagt gar kein richtiges ziel für die
heutige folge ich weiß es nicht in die
hölle gehen will und ich weiß auch dass
ich dort ein bisschen erst mal die tür
zu machen ich weiß dass ich dort ein
bisschen weiter kommen möchte denn in
den letzten folgen in den ich in der
hölle war erst 12 folgen glaube ich in
der hölle da war es allerdings so dass
ich mich nie weit weg bewegen konnte von
meinem sport in der hölle deswegen
meine lieben freunde
wenn wir uns heute versuchen rüber zu
bauen zur festung
[Musik]
ich hab so unfassbar schiss
dass diese dumme
knochen schlange kommt
[Musik]
die sache ist allerdings dass wir erst
auf einer sandra reiten können wenn wir
einen wir pilz gefunden haben um uns
damit eine wir pilz an geld zu machen da
vorne ist noch dieses andere ding was
wir auch irgendwie reiten können nicht
weiß zwar gerade nicht wieder muss man
sich irgendwie für diesen leviathan auch
einen sattel kräften allerdings bleibe
ich glaube ich eher bei den sandras und
da müssen wir einfach so ein wir
baumangel
pilzen und das war halt im ersten
projekt also in der ersten staffel
minecraft mit luca ziemlich easy weil
wir direkt da gespannt sind was dann
natürlich auch blöd wird eine menge
ändern waren allerdings müssen wir hier
und heute ohne das ding aus kommen wir
sind nun allerdings am festland
angekommen ich werde
[Musik]
worauf zu brennen hör auf zu brennen
wie lang brenne ich denn oh mein gott
ich
habe mein halbes leben
auch noch ein gast das ist das doofe
probleme mit diesem seelen sei deshalb
ein ganz klein bisschen tiefer als
normale blöcke das sieht man auch wenn
ihr das hier beispielsweise sieht man
das gar nicht
man sieht ihr seht wenn ich hier so
drauf gehe um mich dann hier rüber
bewege das war so ein bisschen ein sagt
und deswegen wenn ich mich zunehmend
lover bewege fängt man hier halt an zu
brennen sie haben allerdings nun erst
mal keine hunger balken mehr das heißt
unser leben generiert sich wenn auch
sehr langsam
jedoch musste ich erst mal ganz kurz das
fällt mir jetzt auf meine gold stiefel
anziehen so dass diese leute nicht gegen
uns sind ich werde jetzt einfach mal
meine nicht verzauberte also eine
spitzhacke nehmen weil ich dafür ja
leider keine lapislazuli blöcke mehr
hatte jedoch werde ich mir erstmal ganz
kurz das quartz abbauen weil ich weiß
dass ich später im projekt bestimmt
irgendwas mit graz bauen möchte und
jetzt würde ich ja
[Musik]
wir sind direkt mitten drin der gashahn
hat mich angegriffen
[Musik]
daran können sich gast
in luft
auflösen ist allerdings auch egal meine
lieben freunde ich mach mal ganz kurz
das feuerwerk sowie ich mich null die
canon laufe ich da auf jeden fall
irgendwann noch rein ich werde jetzt
mich erstmal nicht in dieser festung
hier reinbauen ich weiß dass ich das
eigentlich vorhatte allerdings fühle ich
mich nicht richtig vorbereitet und ich
glaube es macht mehr sinn dort
reinzugehen wenn wir ihnen noch mehr
diamanten gefunden haben ich möchte
allerdings erstmal hier so ein bisschen
rumlaufen durch den nenner um zu gucken
wo wir uns hier überhaupt befinden
ich weiß dass die mir nichts tun weil
ich gold stiefel anhalt auch
wir haben dort hinten meine lieben
freunde
diese vier bäume das heißt wir kriegen
dort wahrscheinlich wie pilze mit denen
wir eine sandra reiten können wir laufen
hier jetzt mal langsam rein hier wachsen
auf jeden fall ein paar bäume ich weiß
nicht wie groß dieses wir pilz biom ich
weiß nicht ob das so heißt überhaupt ist
und ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht
ob ich hier diese pilze auch gefunden
habe ist eine menge quarz jedoch lasse
ich den erstmal hier überall da sah ich
den ersten mit einer glücks spitzhacke
abbauen möchte dann irgendwann im laufe
des projekts so dass sich dann einfach
mehr quartz blöcke drauf bekommen und
hier haben wir die wilden wie apples das
heißt damit können wir uns auf jeden
fall eine vip zangl machen und demnächst
dann irgendwann sandras auf jeden fall
reiten jedoch möchte ich jetzt erstmal
schauen ob wir vielleicht seine festung
finden also ich weiß ja nicht was das da
vorne war wo wir hin gelaufen sind ob
das vielleicht eine festung war ich
kenne mich ja nicht so richtig auf mit
den ganzen minecraft begriffen jedoch
suche ich halt diesen ort wo diese
wieder skelette herum laufen und ich
weiß nicht wo man sowas vielleicht
finden könnte ob ich mich vielleicht
gerade richtig bewegen wir können ja
auch mal so ein bisschen
die mini mehr blut allerdings ist da
vorne glaube ich nur noch wald
deswegen
werde ich mich auf jeden fall erstmal
wieder zurück bewegen von hier vorne
sind wir gekommen da befindet sich auch
unser portal und ich werde mich jetzt
einfach mal rüber bewegen in diese
richtung hier wir sind ja viel noch da
gelaufen ist wäre natürlich sehr sehr
wild wenn irgendwo in der nähe so eine
festung wäre allerdings komme ich hier
halt nicht mal irgendwie durch das
müsste nur über die lava funktionieren
und da können wir halt aktuell noch
nicht rüber weil ich noch nicht die sind
wie apples angel mehr gekostet habe plus
dafür auch einen sattel benötige die man
sich nicht verhaften sondern nur finden
kann von daher werde ich mich jetzt
einfach mal hier vorne hoch bauen wo ich
vorhin das quartz abgebaut habe und dann
werden wir einfach uns mal langsam an
dieser feste oder wie auch immer das
ding heißt dran vorbei bewegen so dass
wir hier nicht irgendwie eintreten
vielleicht kann man schon mal kurz das
archiv mit abholen das haben wir jetzt
das waren noch zeiten
wir haben diesen ort auf jeden fall
entdeckt dort unten sind ganz ganz viele
leute die mich alle angreifen werden
jedoch haben wir hier natürlich auch
eine menge gold eine menge sachen die
man irgendwie finden kann vielleicht
sogar auch ein bisschen netter ried mit
womit man sich noch bessere sachen als
diamant sachen kräften kann allerdings
laufen wir hier erst mal dran vorbei wir
waren natürlich in minecraft mit lukas
staffel eins sehr vom glück verfolgt
dass wir direkt am spawnen einerseits
eine festung hatten unmittelbar davon
entfernt auf der anderen seite auch noch
diese andere testung mit diesen ganzen
wegen und den boden und so weiter und so
fort jedoch ist es hier glaube ich
wirklich ein bisschen schwieriger so
einen ort zu finden hier vorne geht es
runter und wir haben hier tatsächlich
ein baby
ich habe keine ahnung wo ich
hier jetzt gerade gelandet bin
allerdings wird mich in jedem moment
dieses schwein ihr wahrscheinlich wieder
angreifen so wie ich das ding kenne
ich habe ja keine rüstung ja oh mein
gott ich habe erfolg vergessen dass der
vorschlag war oh mein gott ich
habe voll vergessen dass sich ja in
minecraft mit luca staffel einzeln
diamant rücken hatte und ich deswegen so
easy killen konnte aber das geht ja
nicht mehr vom darf vorne sind wir
gekommen hier befindet sich noch so ein
komisches schweinchen und gerade
deswegen bewege ich mich jetzt mal hier
rüber und bauer auch sogar erst mal ganz
kurz den glos down here ab jetzt gehen
wir allerdings hier weit herum ich weiß
nicht was das hier ist und was passiert
wenn nichts abbaue das hat mich auch
vorhin angegriffen allerdings ist es
gestrüpp einfach okay sind das gebäude
kann ich mir mit dem
jeder fenster greift mich an um ein
paket das hier weiter
hoch kann ich mir mit hellen borten
stammen hollenborg und bretter machen
und auch eine werkbank und auch stöcker
okay das ändert gerade alles weil ich
mir extra jetzt nach dem komischen
vorfall im mai kräften luca staffel 1
hier stärker ohne werkbank mitgenommen
habe allerdings war sie in staffel eins
so dass wir keine holz möglichkeiten
hatten in der hölle jedoch laufen wir
jetzt hier an der stelle einfach mal
hier vorne so ein bisschen weiter über
das gestrüpp kurz rüber so viel schaden
macht mir doch nicht und dann werde ich
mich jetzt auch mal einfach kurz hoch
bauen jedoch wird das glaube ich nichts
bringen weil wir da oben nirgendwohin
kommen werden
also
ich bin
[Musik]
ich bin ganz ehrlich leute
ich werde die hölle jetzt noch nicht
verlassen ich werde mich hier einfach
mal noch ein bisschen aufhalten und mich
vielleicht an der seite kurz so ein
bisschen reinbauen da vorne geht s lang
sehe ich allerdings gerade da kann ich
mir mal eben fix und kleinen weg hier
über bauen und den auch hier vorne mal
ausleuchten so dass ich dir noch von
dort hinten sehen werde jetzt bauen wir
uns einfach mal hier an der seite so ein
bisschen hoch zack zack zack zack
und dann hier noch mal kurz um die kurve
herum so dass wir dann hier vorne in
diesen komischen raum einkehren können
ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt wirklich den
weg es sieht allerdings ziemlich gut aus
um ein gas- und wieder zwei schweine
[Musik]
ist dir was leute
mein typ braucht erst mal in seinem
leben so ein bisschen wieder in vorder
rang zu bringen ich kann gar nicht mehr
richtig reden ich wollte nur sagen dass
ich an der stelle die heute hier wieso
die minecraft mit luke beenden werde wir
haben große teile der hölle bereits
entdeckt allerdings werde ich auch hier
jetzt übernachten beziehungsweise hier
einfach bleiben und hier auch das video
beenden denn ich bin jetzt auf euch
angewiesen schreibt mir unten die
kommentare wie ich so eine festung
situation finden kann denn ich brauche
lohnen routen um generell mit meinem
großen ziel den drachen zu besiegen
weiterzukommen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann lasst dann einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn ihr weitere videos nicht
verpassen wollt wir
ich mache jetzt auch mal ganz kurz pause
weil ich da vorne wieder den gas gesehen
habe wir sehen uns die tage wieder
[Musik]